the primary election is now behind us
looking ahead to the general election
which is in november which will come a
lot faster than i think we think here
we're focusing here on congressional
district four sam peters on the
republican side is uh running to take
the seat sam good to see you sir thank
you so much thanks for having me
appreciate it yeah well let's get into
things a little bit here let's talk a
little bit about your background yeah
you're a veteran you have an insurance
business here in town what about your
experience uh qualifies you or do you
think would be good assets to bring to
congress yeah so i did i spent 20 years
in the military i joined the military
right out of high school
i was an enlisted guy for 10 years i was
a law enforcement canine handler so i
did police work with a dog
and then i commissioned i earned my my
degrees i've got a degree in criminal
justice a master's degree in
administration i learned earned those
along the way i was offered a commission
by the air force and i worked as an
officer i led people i led organizations
i worked on the federal budget the
palming process to build the president's
budget from the bottom up so i know how
that practice works i also worked on uh
projects uh to support security at the
southern border um so i have a back of
background in those type of things
i spent time in iraq and afghanistan i
led people in in those areas i earned a
bronze star in afghanistan as well when
i retired i started a small business i'm
a small business owner i also have small
children that are you know we're
homeschooling at this at this point um
so there's a lot of people a lot of
pieces in my background that fit
together that come together you know the
u.s constitution says law and finance
are the responsibility of the u.s house
of representatives and that's what i'm
that's what i'm running for i've worked
in law enforcement i've worked i
understand law as an officer you have to
understand law as well and i've worked
on that budget that finance piece and oh
by the way i'm an insurance uh i'm in
the insurance world now uh in personal
financial representative as well so i've
got experience in all of those i've also
got a master's degree in again finance
with organizational finance uh
administration with organizational
finance so uh there's a lot of pieces to
my background that that suit me well for
this role um and i'm passionate about it
i love my country we'll talk about the
economic and the immigration issue in
just a few moments here you've run for
this seat before i did
what makes this election different uh so
anytime you get any time you do
something for the first time there's a
learning curve right uh the first in
2020 i ran for the seat there was eight
people in it uh we worked real hard and
we came in a very close second place and
we learned a lot there we gained a lot
of support through that and we brought
that into this election cycle with us
that that support and those those
educational pieces as well so i would
imagine i think under the answer to this
question but in your view is the
environment different for you running
for the gop than it was back in 2020
that
might lead to more success yeah
absolutely i mean it's you know i was i
was an outsider i was a newcomer to uh
to uh the process of running for office
within the political uh sphere you know
you know i'm very involved in my
community i was uh a board member on
rotary clubs i've done a lot of work
with project 150 and those type of
places so very involved in the community
but going into the political uh sphere
of of influence within the community
it's a different uh
a different atmosphere different group
of people and you know the second time
around obviously people knew who i was
let's talk about some of the current
issues uh right now in the country and
obviously one of the the main ones is
the issue of abortion the recent
decision by the supreme court to
overturn roe v wade
you're pro-life anti-abortion pretty
much
go ahead no you hide you'll have the
anti-abortion that's a little that's a
little stretch but let's clarify about
that yeah fair enough so let's clarify
are there any circumstances where you
believe in abortion
is okay so my abortion stance has been
on my website for three years
it's
stampedes4congress.com you can go out
and take a look at it i am a supporter
of
the pain-capable child protection act
which is which limit goes to a 20 week
time frame so the democrats have already
in fact as soon as i won the primary
they came out uh labeled me in certain
ways anti-abortion being one of them
there are circumstances where uh it is
appropriate and the rhetoric now that
sam peters wants to
strip
women of their rights to health care is
an absolute falsehood and i'm not going
to allow that
that to pervade so
the reality of it is
the roe versus weight overturn had zero
effect on nevada law
the naval law was put in place in carson
city and if it's going to change that's
where it's going to change again so
the other piece of that is
while it is an important and historic
overturn
that's not in my opinion
the biggest issue in the american
people's minds our economy is
and what's hitting our pocketbooks every
single day
as a result of this administration uh
and quite frankly uh congressman
horsford and and like we'll touch on the
economy in a second here just to follow
up though uh
you mentioned that in nevada has no
effect and that's a state law obviously
and you're running for congress which is
different
but do you
support keeping nevada's current laws in
place just as a as in nevada
as a nevadan i mean we have to elect
people to carson city to address those
issues i'm running for congress at the
u.s house and again the biggest issues
uh at the federal level are our economy
our immigration issues uh um
from there uh the debt and spending
which goes into the economy in our on
our hyperinflation that we're going into
the recession that's coming all of those
things have to be addressed and i think
those issues are are more forward on
people's minds a final question though
on the roe v wade decision uh there was
a concurrent decision made by a ruling
from justice thomas
and in it there are some discussion from
democrats anyway that
they're concerned about the potential of
reversing previous decisions on gay
marriage issues on contraception things
along those lines should those be
revisited by the court and would you
want to revisit them in congress those
are going to be determined by the court
and again my focus is not those those
social issues my focus is cur is is very
much on economy immigration and those
and crime the crime waves that's going
on in our country right now all of those
things so if the court decides to
revisit that that's on the courts i have
no intention of pushing the court in
that direction
uh there's also right now in washington
the january 6th house select committee
is looking into what took place back in
2021 you talk about election security on
your website as part of your campaign uh
first do you believe the 2020 election
was stolen so the new york times
actually did an article on me a year and
a half ago and my position has not
changed uh the election uh occurred
there were there are questions that
still go unanswered which frankly is
part of the january 6
events that are going on now the the
committees um i think there are things
that we need to do in our election to
tidy them up and make sure
questions and look our elections are are
they have to be uh respected by the
people they have to be accepted by the
people and if the people on whole or in
in majority or a large portion of us of
people in the in the community don't
believe that the election was fair then
let's look at it let's ask those
questions let's get to the bottom of the
other questions and the answers but
let's do it in a civil way let's make
sure that we're doing
doing it legally and you know i'm a fan
of
of voter id across the board um and i
don't think that's that's something you
know that's been painted as uh
disingenuous and and you know
disenfranchising for a certain
population totally disagree with that um
obviously it's a house select committee
if you were in the house now would you
have
asked to be a part of or wanted to be a
part of of this investigation i i would
have i would have been asking questions
whether or not i was allowed on the
committee again
there was a number of republicans that
were denied access to being on the
committee after being selected by the
republicans nancy pelosi denied them
access on it which you know calls into
question the validity of the commission
to my uh the committee as far as i'm
concerned um so that would that would
have been a decision that wouldn't have
been uh mine to make overall what do you
think of what the committee is doing
right now have you watched the uh the
hearings at all do you think it's it's a
dog and pony show what do you what do
you think i think it's a i think there's
a little bit of a witch a lot of a witch
hunt going on there i think it's a lot
of grandstanding and again it's one of
those things that i don't think the
american people
are fully engaged in it because there's
other things on their mind like the
things we've talked about and on that
note let's talk about the economy you
talk about a bunch of different things
and you mentioned the the high inflation
right now one of the aspects of your
campaign you talk about a balanced
budget amendment
explain what you would like to try and
bring to congress on that yeah so a
balanced budget dimension just simply
means that we don't spend more money
than we have to spend we we have or we
keep it within a margin of of of
inflation um you know right now all a
lot of the bills coming out of congress
and uh the senate you know you're
looking at trillion dollar spending
bills um and the trillion dollar
spending bills are not uh spending the
money where the title of the bill would
lead you to believe and the reality of
it is the u.s house again is responsible
for all things law and finance which
includes passing a federal budget which
hasn't been done since 1997 so you could
not come to work for 25 years not do
your job and still have a job and that's
what we're talking about with with
balanced budgets and making sure look we
have a 30 trillion dollar debt it's not
sustainable it's going up every single
year and every single year we're looking
at raising the debt ceiling to allow
more debt that plays into this
inflationary environment and what's you
know six dollars seven dollars eight
dollars gas that's coming uh and it's
and it's something that we have to get
ahead of quickly so if you're elected
into congress what do you do
what do you do to try and balance the
budget try and adjust spending in other
places and and move it someplace else
yeah we stopped spending spending
billions of dollars on gender studies in
pakistan uh we stopped spending 25
million dollars which which was part of
um one of the trillion dollar spending
bills 25 million dollars to you know for
instance the kennedy center so they
don't have to lay off their employees
and then once they got the money they
laid off their employees so you know
those type of things we have to have
some accountability on where our monies
are going and we have to to spend it
smartly um you know billions and
billions of dollars being spent uh on in
fact 300 i think it was in 2019 360
million dollars was were allocated and
spent on programs that no longer have uh
legal standing so you know we have to
get in front of where our federal
government is spending money uh and the
people that are doing there now to
include my opponent uh they are not
doing their job let's talk about
immigration we just saw the tragedy down
in in near san antonio uh this week a
horrible situation dozens of people that
died being brought into the country uh
you talk about finishing the wall
there's there's other elements of
immigration that you mentioned you'd
like to tackle what do you think is the
the most important thing that you would
like to do if you're elected right away
close the border
just close it just close the border we
don't know the people that have the
southern and northern eastern the all we
need to close the the southern border
where the caravans are coming in
millions of people are coming in is is
focus number one we have to get a handle
on no question all of these other
borders as you mentioned because it's
you know all of our ports our
international airports the northern
border becomes
is can become a problem as well
if people are trying to come in
illegally and we just we shore up one
border and people start coming through
another that's obviously a problem so um
yes we have to we've had over two
million or nearly two million illegal
immigrants come into the country people
that we know of uh there's been a number
of that we don't know of obviously and
you know the people that are coming into
the country represent over a hundred
countries uh from around the world many
of them on the terror watch list and
they're coming through the southern
border through mexico so one of the
things that i would do is like i
mentioned uh we need to close the border
and we need to finish the wall and again
these are there's there's a plan on my
website you can see that there against
sampedersforcongress.com
these are steps that we need to take
immediately and then we need to hold
mexico accountable because they hold
some
responsibility for this and allowing
those caravans to come through but
beyond as you suggest
finishing the wall and
closing the borders is there a more
nuanced is there a more legislative uh
tact that can be taken beyond just
the physical nature of closeness
it's a bigger issue than just that no it
absolutely is and it's it's an actually
a rewrite of our federal immigration
laws in fact
the supreme court just this morning
made mention of the fact that congress
has um
law that's written that allows
interpretation um and it doesn't say and
and they said in the justice roberts i
believe it was said in his decision that
uh if congress wanted to make it
mandatory they would have said it
clearly and i think that's what we need
to do we need to make make the law much
more clear on what needs to happen when
people enter this country illegally they
should be removed
i feel like tackling immigration has
been a challenge for republicans and
democrats for as long as i can remember
it is what's going to be different it's
a tough situation it absolutely
absolutely is but we have to take look
our country is uh we have a country
that's sovereign we have a
responsibility to the citizens and those
who want to immigrate here and if we
don't develop a clear concise um and
appropriate immigration platform uh and
law then we're going to continue having
these problems the federal government
over decades has created this issue and
we need to fix it and it's going to be a
tough scenario but we have to have
courage to do it final question i touch
on you mention your years in the
military and your service in the
military what are some of the issues
that you think need to be addressed
right away with the defense department
and and for veterans well i think
veterans one of the first things i would
do and i've commented on this recently
the people who have
been denied their religious exemptions
from taking the covet shot and removed
from the military these are these are
heroes these are people who are fighting
for their country have stood up to fight
for america and and they've been denied
their first amendment right and removed
from service i would like to see them um
put back in service if they would
volunteer to do so um without prejudice
and uh let them serve their country as
they've decided and we've paid and
trained them to do um that's that's you
know top of mind for me right now but
there's a lot of work to be done in
department of defense as well obviously
they have gone the department of defense
leadership has gone in a very um
woke ideology um and teaching uh
you know there's teachings of critical
race theory i've seen letters and memos
just recently that have gone out that
are just in my opinion inappropriate so
i would i would be very interested in
being on
the committees that would have those
discussions
and make sure that the military and the
department of defense is focused
fully on defending the united states
against its aggressors and we have
aggressors that we need to be defending
against what's inappropriate about some
of the things that you're talking about
well critical race theories critical
race theory is absolutely inappropriate
from a government standpoint
forcing people to judge on race color
and
you know nationality and others
that is the basis of of critical race
theory and it needs to
we we can do better than that we're all
americans we're citizens we we
again i love my country and i don't
judge you based on your
your opinions your the color of your
skin or anything else and i don't think
we should be doing that in the military
sam peters running for congressional
district four as a republican good luck
in your campaign sir we'll keep in touch
as things go along thank you so much
thanks for having me